At first the systems of error
catching in Objective C and
Swift, may seem pretty different.
But errors actually travel between
the two languages remarkably well.
In Objective C, returning a false value
in this case would constitute an error.
Now you might think that this BOOL
return value could cause a problem.
But swift doesn't have
to bother with the BOOL.
Let's take a look at how an error
causing function like this one
would be translated in Swift.
If we look in the generated header,
we see that the Swift version of
the method doesn't have a BOOL.
It just throws an error that can be
caught just like any other sort of Swift
style error would be caught.
Also notice,
that there's no more error parameter and
the width error at the end of
the method name has been removed.
In Objective C, an error can
also be signaled when a method
with an error parameter
returns a nil value.
Let's take a look at
the generated header for
this perform some action
on string method.
Now as a Swift developer.
I'm sure your ears perked up
at the mention of a nil value.
But don't worry, we can handle that nil
value in the same way we would handle
any other error-throwing
function that returns a value.
With the tri-question mark construct.
Notice that the return type for this
function is just a plain old string.
Not an optional.
Since Swift generally uses enums for
errors.
It's straightforward to catch specific
errors and define customized responses.
And you can still do this when
your code is consuming NSErrors.
With a defined set of
common error codes that is.
Even though NSError doesn't
encode errors as enums.
The properties of NSError
have been defined,
such that the most common errors
can be accessed using dot syntax.
Like so.
You can find a list of the available
NSError codes in
the Foundation Constants Reference,
linked in the accompanying text.
The bottom line when your Swift code
is consuming errors from objective C,
is that apart from using
the class name NSError.
You can pretty much treat an NSError
as you would treat a SwiftError.